do you remember that strange teaser from  bandai namco last week well now we know  what it's for  I'm Tony and this is your newly revealed  GameSpot news update I don't want to  brag but I totally called it this is an  RPG about vampires  it's called code vain and it's coming  from the team behind the God Eater  series code vain is set in a  post-apocalyptic world where vampires  called reven it's fight for blood or  risk becoming something called a lost  and now that prepared a dying call out  makes a whole lot more sense and not  just because the Dark Souls publisher is  behind this game code Vayne isn't  expected until 2018 and no platforms  have been announced but I expect plenty  of new info and trailers in the future  so be sure to subscribe to keep up with  all of it and for some bloody violence  right now you can check out our live  stream of Ghost Recon wildlands narco  road DLC  [Music]  you